du grand chose réservoir et à motiver
pour beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai temps
sont durs la sécheresse inquiète
nous traversons une période difficile
mais tâchons de rester solidaires de
nous rassembler
samba suis beau gosse qui est superbe
bonne fête à tue tête quand tu veux ton
a été ensuite tu les fais rire j'aime
bien sûr j'aimerais qu'on parle de
joseph vous où il ya revenus traîner
dans la ferme et il ya plusieurs temps
de la fameuse contis paris qu'est ce que
tu as été faire danser revanche je suis
poli mais c'est vrai que moi bon bah je
ferai la commerciaux s'arrêtent joseph
les gens se plaignent tu fatigues tout
le monde avec tes conneries tu vas voir
tu as à votre mari s'est passé quelque
chose
joseph est de l'attachement pour toi tu
t'en as pas sous c'est plutôt change feu
de ma fille tu es mort bozouls
votre fille n'a t'elle pas déposé
plainte pourquoi je l'aurais forcé tu
sais qu'il est revenu
fruits ils respectent pas les règles
comme tout le monde j'ai fait exprès sa
faute ce jour il fait une vraie connerie
faudra parce que quand on a traversé le
village et les gendarmes qui mettait des
banderoles portant pour faire quelque
chose c'est bien agréable
oui